I cannot believe this but according to
my paperwork here there is pornography
on the computer you guys heard about
that did you did you know about that I
had no idea Kim did you know about that
I am shocked sir it is quite shocking
and appalling yes but apparently it's
true and now Google is gonna start
cracking down on it at least on their
blogger service we've got a little more
info for you so this is the policy that
they're going to institute now and then
I'll tell you about what they've been
doing before this starting on March 23rd
2015
you won't be able to publicly share
images and video that are sexually
explicit or show graphic nudity on
blogger will still allow nudie if the
content offers a substantial public
benefit for example in artistic
educational documentary or scientific
context and then the changes that you're
gonna see to existing blog so this is if
you have a blogspot account if your
existing blog doesn't have any sexually
explicit content you won't notice any
changes if your existing blog does have
sexually explicit or graphic nude images
or video your blog will be made private
after March 23rd 2015 no content will be
deleted but private content can only be
seen by the owner or administrators of
the blog and the people who the owner
has shared the blog with so just real
quick basically up until this point a
blogger did allow adult content so you
can get porn on blogger right now but
the all the person had to do the
administrator was just mark it as adult
and you just click check and you're good
to go so they're cracking down on this
stuff a little bit my general thing with
this is that there's so much porn online
and Google's a big company like what are
they what are they is this like what is
the moral majority non-set like what are
they what are they going for here I
think that making sure that someone
checks off on a box indicating that
they're 18 or older to watch the content
whatever is fine and that's what they
okay you guys can do that right but I
just like it's the Internet I would say
like 82 percent of the Internet is
pornography that was a made-up statistic
obviously I'm exaggerating it's probably
a 92 it's a probably but I think that I
just get scared with this kind of stuff
because the one thing that's great about
the Internet is how free it is right and
so whenever I give Lex
to my college students always tell them
like if you want to work in new media
there's a huge upside you don't have to
worry about FCC regulations you can cuss
if you want to cuss you can have
sexually explicit content you know in
some of your videos if that's what you
really want but YouTube crackdown on
that Google cracks down on that I mean
it's the same company but you get what I
mean and it's like we're adults let us
make the content that we think is
favorable to our audience and just stop
policing us yeah I mean that's pretty
much how I yeah I see it I mean it seems
to me that if people want porn they're
gonna find it one way or another so if
Google just wants less clicks and they
want to make it more difficult so be it
people will just go elsewhere you agree
I want you all to know that tumblr.com
does not have these regulations that URL
no ii are.com you can blog whatever the
[ __ ] you want right early but you know
look this is just my hypothesis yeah and
it's just based on what I've noticed
with YouTube and advertisers people are
less likely to advertise on YouTube
videos if it's not family-friendly right
so I'm wondering if you know Google is
having a harder time selling you know
Adsense ads or whatever on some of these
blogs because hey you know what it might
have some sexually explicit content and
it might be difficult to sell ads I
don't know right I don't know what their
business model is there but it always
comes down to the money the advertisers
who are big [ __ ] [ __ ] who can't
handle some x-rated content grow a set
of [ __ ] balls people watch porn
people have sex
people have vaginas and penises and
we're gonna be fine I'm just I'm so
tired of having to tiptoe and walk on
eggshells because people have kids if
you have kids be a [ __ ] parent and
keep an eye on what they're watching if
adults want to post explicit content
they should be able to do it on the
Internet and advertisers again grow a
set of balls please well Anna just
answered my next six questions though
you know people ask often on YouTube why
do you guys do sex videos why do you
guys do drug videos I mean a lot of I
just think are interesting but to Anna's
point people click on them just no
matter how much porn there is online
people still come to YouTube for people
to talk about porn or sex or whatever it
is and then ironically those videos do
out the least yeah so a lot of times the
things that are getting the most clicks
in this little digital world we live in
actually make us the least amount of
money which is a whole other other topic
altogether do you guys think we're gonna
look back at like the last like ten
years as the golden age of the internet
because we just did the story a second
ago about the government wanting to look
at Isis on Twitter regulate some of that
stuff now we're talking about it with
bloggers and sex do you think that
there's we're entering the second phase
now I mean if we don't get net
neutrality yeah that was the Golden Age
and we're over it yeah I'm already
hearing though that even this net
neutrality think I heard this long
interview with Mark Cuban yesterday and
he was even saying that the that the net
neutrality that they're passing isn't
even gonna be as good as what we all
thought which is a whole other issue
yeah I think that people are starting to
realize that audiences are transferring
from television to online and once that
happens you're gonna have governments
and certain individuals wanting to
regulate it and wanting to censor it and
I think it's problematic but I think
that it's gonna be a lot more difficult
to do that with the internet compared to
what they did with television yeah there
you go on a story like this even if you
think it's just silly because it's about
porn really it starts there and then
it's what can the regulations do down
the road that's why I think something
like this is important what do you think
let us know in the comments right now
[Music]